si certains policiers une minorité
agissante
ont manqué à leurs devoirs le devoir des
responsables de la République c'est de
frapper et de faire respecter l'autorité
de l'État 8 juin 1983 le président de la
République François Mitterrand attaque
frontalement la police mais pourquoi
autant de fermeté en direct à la
télévision on rembobine d'effet
retour 9 jours plus tôt le 31 mai 1983
ce jour-là deux policiers sont tués lors
d'une fusillade avenue Trudaine à Paris
Emile Gondry et Claude Cayola une
brigade en civile de lutte contre le
cambriolage effectue une ronde dans le
quartier carte gardien de la paix trois
hommes une femme il repère trois hommes
et une femme également chargés de gros
sacs de plastique et qui s'affaire entre
une porte cochère une voiture intriguée
par ce manège suspect les policiers
demandent leurs papiers d'identité à
deux des individus ceci ouvre le fait
immédiatement le brigadier tué un
gardien blessé en fuyant les malfaiteurs
tuent un second gardien de la paix ce
fait divers va vite prendre une
attention très politique pour le
contexte nous sommes deux ans après
l'arrivée de la gauche au pouvoir qui a
aboli dans la foulée la peine de mort
les opposants de la majorité et certains
syndicats de police dénonçaient à
l'époque le laxisme de la justice nos
deux collègues décédés que vous venez de
voir tuer assassiné mais c'est l'échec
de la politique de la criminalité en
France avant d'avoir une politique
claire et bien définie de la sécurité on
commence par s'apitoyer sur le sort des
détenus le fait divers fait les gros
titres de la presse et la droite attaque
à l'image de Jacques Chirac alors mère
de Paris qui met publiquement en cause
le gouvernement Robert Badinter ministre
de la justice lui répond sèchement on a
mis en cause la justice française
trop facilement et trop aisément ces
derniers jours
et cela je ne l'accepterai pas je marque
aussi pour faire savoir que tu parles de
termes de laxisme on dit n'importe quoi
et les mensonges je marque aussi que
depuis que je suis garde des sceaux il
n'y a jamais eu de libération
conditionnelle ou de mesure de grâce
pour l'auteur d'un meurtre d'une
tentative de meurtre comme une contre un
policier le 3 juin la situation bascule
une cérémonie en hommage aux deux
policiers est organisé à la préfecture
de police de Paris à la sortie du
cortège funèbre le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gaston de fer et chahuter
quelques minutes plus tard le cortège
gonflé à bloc prend la direction de la
place Vendôme pour manifester sous les
fenêtres du ministère de la Justice au
cri des bas d'Inter assassins le
rassemblement dégénère au milieu
Jean-Marie Le Pen du Front national
bousculade avec un faible cordon de
garde mobile on frise l'incident mais la
manifestation déborde et prend le chemin
du ministère de l'Intérieur place
Beauvau aujourd'hui curieusement les CRS
ne se posent pas vraiment à cette
manifestation la plus importante de
policiers depuis 1979 son métro pour
l'exécutif qui dénonce des troubles à
l'ordre public le directeur général de
la police nationale et limogé le préfet
de police de Paris démissionne des
policiers et responsables syndicaux sont
sanctionnés les commissaires présents
sur le terrain messieurs loyaz et
Querrien n'aurait pas donné l'ordre
d'employer la force pour empêcher les
manifestants de parvenir jusqu'au
ministère de l'Intérieur les barrages en
CD ils sont sanctionnés
devant le ministère les CRS de la
septième compagnie avaient sympathisé
avec les manifestants les responsables
sont suspendus du côté syndical Rémi
alvax organisateur de la manifestation
spontanée entre guillemets de vendredi
matin au cours de laquelle on a pu
entendre crier Badinter assassin ou de
faire des missions et révoquer de son
poste de gardien de la paix 4000
fonctionnaires ont participé à une
marche
rassemblement et je suis le seul
sanctionné donc ma réaction je suis
sanctionné politique tout simplement le
lendemain François Mitterrand prend la
parole pour dénoncer des événements
qu'il qualifie de séditieux c'est à moi
de décider ce qu'il convient de décider
et non pas à ceux qui veulent se
substituer au pouvoir en criant dans la
rue
cette réponse
implique que mes responsabilités je les
assume moi-même et je me considère comme
le premier responsable des affaires
publiques quant aux meurtriers des deux
policiers on apprendra plus tard qu'ils
étaient membres du groupe muscul
d’extrême gauche action directe Régis
schlicher sera condamné en 1987 à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité sans
complices Nicolas halfen à 10 ans de
prison pour association de malfaiteurs
[Musique]